read the piece the part that was most
interesting to me is you break down
um historically people think of creators
as creators
first and then they may be able to
figure out how to monetize that
what all of these platforms have done
though is they've allowed entrepreneurs
whether they're venture funded you know
kind of tech types
uh founders or just entrepreneurial in
nature
to now start to build these content
businesses right it's almost like the
the cost of starting one of these
businesses has drastically been driven
down by the substance by the youtubes
by the podcasting platforms very similar
to what we saw let's say with server
costs right
there was an explosion of startups uh
that that
happened because simply now you could
spin up aws rather than have to go buy a
server and set it up
and so that to me is interesting because
what you
get is a blurring of the line right is
somebody who
um you know let's take away all of our
investing activity everything if you
just look at the things that i've done
in on the content side
is it that you're an entrepreneur or is
it that you're a creator and what's the
difference
right and you can kind of go down
whether it's the sub stack list or or
other platforms
and you start to actually look at the
skill set that's necessary
is very different than the skill set of
hey just go work inside the media
company
right and and so i think that that's the
other piece of this where everyone's
like oh all the
uh all the journalists are gonna leave
the media organizations like ah
there's a lot of people who actually are
not entrepreneurial that not at all like
they're scared
they just want to like stay where they
are safe get a salary
and they're perfectly happy but it's not
a bad thing that they're happy doing
that
but then there is a subset of people and
the question is how big is that subset
that want to go do this and i think
that's kind of what you're hitting at
here is
are those people creators that were
doing it already and now building a
business
or were they business people who now are
seeing an opportunity and they're coming
in and creating uh
what any kind of content really yeah
yeah no
i mean it's so right on right i think i
think everybody
a lot of people are saying like okay
when you go and become your own
you know creator business you go and
create a sub stack you go and create
you know a brand on tick tock um that
now you get to just focus on
doing what you do best creating and it's
the opposite it's like
when you decide to go and do that you're
actually assuming the business of your
entire self
you're basically saying yes i'm going to
create but i am now
choosing and willingly going to take on
all of this work
in order to help build my brand my
business and really try to figure out
entrepreneurially
how we go there and that's a totally
different skill set um
i think that's why right now
some of like the earliest people in this
space especially
like in that sub stack crew but even
newsletter creators like webb smith
um that have done it outside um they're
here to stay
right i think everyone who's kind of in
at this moment
has really figured out what they need to
do in order to kind of like support
their own business
how to kind of manage certain times how
to focus on distribution and really be
able to see what's next
um the next but that also on top of that
i think that's also um an
acknowledgement that
we probably have one percent of the
creators that are like
interested and willing to like leave and
do it because of that
um that need for them to be able to own
it all right that's a particular person
that could really do that this next
phase of like
creator economy passion economy or
whatever you want to call it
there's so much focus and people that
i'm talking about that are or people
that i'm talking to and
um people that are investing in this
space around that notion of
comfort and confidence right so if you
know that right now it takes a
particular creator
who really understands not just how to
build audience and create but also
manage a business
then how do you start to attract the
millions and millions and millions of
other people
who would be willing to come over and do
this if
they weren't so nervous about health
insurance if they weren't so nervous
about getting sued and liable
if they weren't so um nervous about the
fact that they don't have an editor or
don't have a designer or don't have
newsroom support
and what's incredible is that is not
going to be a catalyst for people to not
come over that's actually going to be a
catalyst for builders
to build those products and build those
sort of networks and marketplaces and
support
in order to recognize that that pool is
a ton of people
that would be willing and interested to
come over if those things are built so
that's really like
the next phase of what's happening here
i think phase one was okay
can creators go out and do this on their
own and are there enough tools for them
to be able to actually
create and put content out there now
it's okay how do we build things that
help support that business
which kind of goes full circle to the
emphasis of media companies at record
labels
it's not really a choice i think if they
if they don't figure out
how to structure their companies in
order to focus on creators
and build for creators to manage that
sort of talent and delivery
then these companies are going to be
built outside of them and things are
just going to run
right so it's kind of no longer a choice
but more so
starting to kind of make that transition
and make that approach but
one more thing that's really interesting
on top of that though is like and i talk
about this in renaissance creator is
that
newsletters kind of had the same effect
as streaming in a very weird way
right like the music industry was kind
of dead
uh when napster came out and napster
didn't come out because people wanted
free music right napster was
basically developed because no one could
stand the ux of the music experience no
one wanted to buy
um a 20 cd you know at whatever your
local record store was
for a single track um nobody likes like
how bulky and um kind of the cost
structure and everything around that
experience
to the point where like sean parker and
code built napster
to basically say okay we're going to
build an experience that consumers
actually want when it comes to listening
to music
and what came out of that right via
spotify
was that not only did people stop
stealing music but now they're paying
for it right because it's an experience
they like it's a relationship they like
there's a ton of arguments that can be
thrown at me which i get all the time at
twitter which is like is it better for
the artist
separate conversation but for the
consumer right napster and streaming
really kind of broke through and built a
better business
for music than it was when it was
totally broken down via the napster er
newsletters are kind of the same right
like we're forgetting now because of all
the
media growth that two or three years ago
you had an ad blocker on right you
didn't want to go to a
site and read content and see ads and
you chose to turn that blocker on
you would bypass paywalls constantly
right like you like
mainly like maybe you wouldn't even go
and see that content or you'd type the
url into google
and you'd circumvent it you did not want
to pay for content
and you didn't not want to pay for
content because you didn't believe
content was valuable you just didn't
like that experience
right and what newsletters have done in
a very weird way
is really broken that one-to-one
relationship again right and
there's like weird synergies it's like i
get
say i get your newsletter in my inbox
there's nothing stopping me from
forwarding your newsletter
to 10 11 i mean there's tracking and
stuff but there's ways to go about it
but nobody does that right nobody does
that because there's a relationship with
the creator
they like the way that it's being
delivered to them they like the
experience there's a value exchange
and they know what they're paying for
and they think that that's valuable and
they're getting that back
so it's kind of changed like the
newsletter ecosystem
has kind of also changed the way that
the broader media ecosystem
really thinks about the value of content
because of that and i kind of believe
that
it was like less severe but the napster
moment was kind of ad blocking
paywalls users are fed up with that way
of navigation content
here comes newsletters or independent
creators that are building a new
relationship value exchange
and now all of a sudden people are like
oh yeah content is valuable and i do
like this and media companies are
starting to adjust
the way that they operate in order to
accommodate that ux
and it's kind of a similar sort of slope
um that i think is just really
really really badass to pay attention to